because you know ahaha oh man hey you
just got us playing some Super Smash
Brothers Brawl here at the wired offices
now um super smash brothers melee for
Nintendo GameCube was Nintendo's biggest
selling GameCube game ever and they're
poised to do the same thing with brawl
now in Japan were brawl shipped last
month and we're playing the Japanese
version right now they sold over a
million copies in its first two weeks of
availability making it the fastest
selling Wii game ever and you're gonna
get to experience the same thing here in
America on March 9th and what do you
have to look forward to we're gonna show
you so stick around
you're watching game life
here's all you need to know about the
super smash brothers series all-star
Nintendo characters like Mario link and
Pikachu get together and bash each other
in the fence as you can imagine the four
player battles are non-stop chaos Super
Smash Brothers Brawl ups the ante with
the addition of the final smash when the
glowing blue smash ball descends into
the arena it's every player for himself
trying to be the first to break it do so
and you'll powerup at this point
pressing your smash attack button will
unleash an insane move guaranteed to do
huge damage to your opponent's Pikachu
turns into a giant ball of lightning
that you can zoom around the screen
Mario launches his biggest fireball ever
Princess Peach puts everyone to sleep
and creates of course some delicious
peaches in addition to featuring
characters from all over the Nintendo
universe Smash Brothers lets you fight
it out in all kinds of places from the
Olympian palaces of Kid Icarus to the
underground sewers of Mario Brothers but
in case that's not enough for you Smash
Brothers Brawl adds a stage creator by
dragging and dropping elements you can
make your very own smash stages any way
you like even better you can send them
to your friends over the internet even
better than that you can submit them to
Nintendo will pick one stage per day to
send out to all players over the net oh
and of course you can battle online too
but Beauty back right now as we all know
the Wii has a wide variety of controller
options and you can use all of them for
Super Smash Brothers Brawl
you can use the Wiimote and held on its
side like a retro gaming pad you can use
the Wii mote coupled with a nunchuck you
can use the classic controller or you
can use one of your old gamecube pads
these people are awesome
but you shouldn't have to tie yourself
down to just one controller options one
of brawls greatest unsung features
that's really impressed us is the
controller configuration stream now
everybody's got a different idea about
how to play some people want the a
button to jump other people wanted to do
a special attack in Brawl everybody wins
you can create a profile add your name
to it and then save your own personal
button settings for each of the four
controller options then when you select
your profile on the character select
screen the game will automatically
detect what kind of controller you're
using and make sure you have the right
button set up you know and those are
only just a few of the awesome new
features that are gonna make Super Smash
Brothers Brawl an incredible party game
you know with so many new characters and
new stages and new things to do I can't
imagine this ever getting old I am just
sorry that you guys can't play it right
now to the delay - March 9th ISM is a
big bummer for a Nintendo fans but trust
me the weight is gonna be worth it now I
don't want to rub it in or anything but
if you'll excuse me I have to go play
some Smash Brothers now see it
oh hi I'm Chris Kohler you know we have
a lot of fun here on game life but today
I need to talk to you about something
serious do you know how many children go
to bed in this country without ever
having done a logic puzzle logic puzzle
deficiency disorder effects I don't know
like millions of Americans leaving them
unable to tell you how to get a fox a
chicken and a bag of grain across a
river without the Fox eating the chicken
or worse the chicken eating the grain
you can help
by buying your loved one a copy of
Professor Layton in the Curious Village
for the Nintendo DS packed with over a
hundred and thirty different logic
puzzles it's one of the best Nintendo DS
games that we've ever played in fact
it's so good that we gave Professor
Layton in the Curious Village rating of
9 out of 10 for more information go to
blog dot wired.com slash games slash
2008 /o 2 slash leighton dot html' thank
you good night
you